I I really don't have any I really don't
want to think about that because I have
probably so many if I began to think
about it seriously I'll give up uh no I
just I would rather just keep moving
forward uh biggest mistake
oh that's endless how long do we have
tonight here now uh where's okay there's
been a few casting mistakes
um
happening jabbawockee the first one I
did there's a a particular actor I don't
know if he's still alive or not but he
played the the leading Merchant and
there's a point in the film where I was
going to introduce this character and it
was going to be on a hand asleep you
actually saw it later on in Time Bandits
it was that I used it for the ogre in
time balance and then a light was uh
curtains going to be drawn and the light
was going to hit on him and then it was
going to go scratching around I guess we
were going to follow the hand until it
went up into the nose up close up and
and a guy picks his nose now the actor
of the day we were going to do it the
bit of the script had been there and the
day we're going to do it it was short of
time always and he said
I'm not going to do that it's disgusting
and I said and the clock is running he
said you know I'd rather expose myself
than do that and and it was one of those
moments you start arguing and then in
the end you know very quickly we're
running out of time oh and also his one
of the the one who's the maid who opened
the curtain was standing behind me yes I
think it's disgusting too I think it's
absolutely horrible and it basically
rather than saying [ __ ] off I said okay
okay and then I go in there and
completely rearrange what we're do it it
happened again with Ralph Richardson but
this is a really nice one because I
gotta do sorry my long answers but you
you ask a question
when we were doing time balance I spent
a lot of time with Ralph which is going
over every detail every word in the
script everything because he didn't want
to have any gray areas when he arrives
on the set let's work it all out in
advance and so the day he arrives on the
set and at that point we've got David
Warner has been blown up and he's in
there's a statue a charcoal statue of
him and Richardson walks on the set he's
looking around he said he says what's
this so I say well it's evil and no no
this is not this is wrong this is
completely wrong I mean I mean the
problem is my problem is I've got to
stop OG the pig eating a piece of evil
and this is not you've got to break it
up into little pieces I said what and
but I'd learned my lesson by then rather
than arguing I said I tug my forelock I
ran after him yes sir whatever whatever
and I just groveled and he had made his
Mark he'd established his position which
was very important I then over lunch had
the statue broken up and then we rewrote
things we did all sorts of things we
made it work but what was so nice is he
had taken charge and after that I could
ask him to do anything stand there
surrounded by a bunch of dwarves acting
backwards while dry ice is dumped on
your head he was happy as Larry because
he was in charge by that and that's what
I learned from these kinds of situations
yeah you don't want to get it into a
fight find a way around it uh and also
be careful who you hire
and that first actor Elder hire again
Richardson is gone unfortunately sadly
he was wonderful